pixar's critically acclaimed blockbuster
cars came out nearly two decades ago so
a lot of the kids who were mesmerized by
the movie in 2006 are now old enough to
notice its many other layers including
jokes references and quite frankly some
very weird things that only adults
noticed
there aren't any outright dirty jokes
hidden in cars but there are a lot of
suggestive ones that sail right over the
heads of its five-year-old fans
for example lightning mcqueen is a
famous race car and he's got the
groupies to prove it
after his big race at the beginning of
the movie two red cars named mia and tia
proclaimed to be his biggest fans and
then literally flash him with their
headlights
later in the movie's central location of
the sleepy town of radiator springs
lightning meets sally who has a tribal
style pinstriping tattoo just above her
bumper the car's equivalent of a [ __ ]
stamp lower back tattoo in another scene
lightning barges in on doc hudson in his
garage
or rather doctor's office where he's got
sheriff elevated to examine his
undercarriage sheriff asks lightning if
he got quote a good peek when lightning
tells mater and the other cars that he
discovered doc hudson was once a
three-time winner of the illustrious
racing championship the piston cup mater
shouts out
he did what in his cup if you don't get
it say piston cup out loud three times
fast
the names of characters and the actors
filmmakers hired to play those
characters offer many references that
only parents in the know old movie fans
and car enthusiasts would be hip to for
example the late comedian and counter
cultural icon george carlin gave voice
to fillmore a hippie volkswagen bus
the kind of car countless real hippies
drove
champion racecar the king is voiced by
richard petty the nascar legend known as
the king even ray maliatsi and his late
brother tom aka click and clack
long-time hosts of national public radio
mainstay car talk have cameos they play
the owners of rusty's the bumper
ointment company that sponsors lightning
mcqueen radiator springs diner
equivalent flows v8 cafe is operated by
a former show car named flo her job on
screen primarily consists of server-like
duties this parallels that of florence
jean castleberry or just flow the sassy
waitress played by polly holliday on the
popular 70s sitcom alice
as in the human world car racing is a
hugely popular sport in cars but the
cars aren't driving automobiles like
humans do in the real world instead
they're essentially racing around a
track using their actual bodies that
means auto racing in cars is essentially
a super fast super competitive track and
field event it's also very high stakes
and highly competitive cars bump each
other and jockey for position at high
speeds leaving each other in the dust or
slammed against the wall
spin-outs collisions and accidents
happen relatively frequently in real
world auto racing events but the cars
are so packed with protective equipment
that drivers rarely get hurt the
vehicles take a lot of damage but fans
don't think too much about it because
those cars don't feel pain
but they do in cars think about it even
the most minor racing incident is more
or less a horrific injury
getting a piece of the car's body
knocked off that's like if a human
runner lost a body part mid-race a blown
tire the equivalent of a shattered foot
viewed this way the aggressive racing
style of the villainous chick hicks
which causes the king to roll over
multiple times equates to gladiatorial
combat with intent to harm or kill
pixar is known for lacing its films with
well-hidden jokes and easter eggs and
cars is no exception
ever since its first appearance in toy
story the beat up yellow pizza planet
delivery truck has made an appearance in
almost every pixar movie so it makes
perfect sense that it would show up in
cars a movie populated entirely with
motorized vehicles the pizza planet
truck appears for just a quick flash as
part of a crowd scene before one of
lightning mcqueen's big races
in creating the car's world everything
about the human world had to be
translated into its car equivalent
usually it works cow tipping has been
replaced with tractor tipping and flo's
v8 cafe serves gas and oil rather than
food for example however not everything
is a direct parallel making for some
very strange moments
one example of this is how lightning
mcqueen travels from race to race as is
the case with the real world race car
he's hauled around in the back of a
specially built truck
in cars that truck is presented as
something between a private jet and a
limousine stocked with amenities to
ensure maximum comfort for lightning but
because this is the world of sentient
cars the truck is a living thing
this means mack drives down the freeway
with lightning mcqueen literally inside
of him
this is akin to a private jet pilot who
keeps rich clients in his stomach
kids can watch cars on a surface level
cars do stuff cars learn lessons cars
race older people however may be left
wondering how and why is the world of
cars this way it's about a place
virtually identical to 21st century
earth only everything is built for cars
rather than humans but they also enjoy
human culture that seems based on our
real world things celebrities and pop
culture moments radiator springs is
situated on the disused route 66 so
what's going on here exactly does cars
take place in an alternate dimension
where automobiles are the dominant
species and humans don't exist or is
this some sort of post-apocalyptic
post-human earth where cars have evolved
and taken over for the now extinct human
race either option feels like it could
just as easily be the plot of a horror
movie rather than a film for children
what this place is crazy
younger viewers in pixar's target
audience for the film may not even be
able to read yet but they probably still
wouldn't understand the adult nature of
the fictional products being pitched in
cars
for example mack and lightning mcqueen
drive past the top down truck stop which
proudly boasts its convertible
waitresses in the land of cars it means
that the servers can take their tops
down in other words they're topless
lightning mcqueen's primary race sponsor
is rusty's a bumper ointment it's a
topical cream for a car's rear end or
the automotive equivalent of preparation
h a product humans use to treat
hemorrhoids a major supplier of gasoline
to the cars of cars is dynaco as gas is
food to automobiles this would make it
the equivalent of a human food
conglomerate adult viewers may also
recognize it as a link to other pixar
movies the pizza planet truck in toy
story stops in to refuel at a dynaco
station
while some of the car characters and
cars perfectly embody their name others
are known by names that reflect their
make model or function designations that
would be clear only to adults or viewers
with at least a passing knowledge of
automobile history for instance in his
career as a race car lightning mcqueen
gets around from race to race in the
back of a big mack truck a friendly
helpful behemoth whose name is literally
mac prickly radiator springs physician
doc hudson is named after and has the
appearance of a hudson hornet a super
fast car of 1950s vintage differently
local hotel operator sally carrera gets
her name from the carrera model of
porsche of which she is an example
radiator springs town founder stanley is
named for the stanley steamer an early
steam-powered car while his surviving
spouse lizzie gets her name from the
nickname for the ford model t also known
as a tin lizzy
radiator springs old town doctor doc
hudson is voiced by late hollywood
legend paul newman who also raced
professionally older viewers of cars may
remember that newman played a speedy
driver on screen in the 1969 movie
winning which hit theaters a year after
bullet an action-packed police movie
that featured one of the most legendary
car chase scenes ever shot that film
starred steve mcqueen who famously did
much of his own stunt work and had
earned a reputation in films like the
great escape as a fearless driver
mcqueen was a hot shot on the asphalt on
screen and off not unlike lightning
mcqueen with whom the actor shares a
name
so in the first cars movie doc hudson is
initially dismissive and openly hostile
toward lightning with the animosity
alluding to a real-life conflict between
mcqueen and newman at the peak of their
success in the 1960s and 1970s paul
newman and steve mcqueen were seen as
hollywood rivals often competing for the
same roles mcqueen was nearly cast in
butch cassidy in the sundance kid but
turned the role down when he learned
newman would be getting top billing
mcqueen later made a passion project out
of the 1971 film le mans where he played
a driver who delivered the famed line
racing it
to life
anything that happens before or after
just waiting paul newman took things one
step further in 1979 when he raced a
porsche 935 in the real le mans
finishing first in his class and second
overall in a rain-soaked race in 1974
the duo were paired together on screen
for the first and only time in the
blockbuster film the towering inferno
when mcqueen got his script for the
irwin allen disaster flick he counted
out his lines to see if he had more than
newman
while on the surface it's a kids movie
about talking cars pixar's cars is a
poignant tale of redemption of one
individual realizing what's important in
life this is a story of choices regrets
and one laced with melancholy which has
way more appeal to adults than it does
to kids
it also might feel familiar because
older viewers may already have consumed
this story in a very similar form in
1991 michael j fox starred in the
live-action comedy movie doc hollywood a
moderate box office hit that lived on
for years thanks to home video and cable
tv re-airings it has almost the exact
same plot as cars released 15 years
later
fox played cocky young plastic surgeon
dr ben stone driving across the country
in his red sports car until he crashes
it in grady south carolina as a sentence
for the property damage he causes he's
forced to work in the local hospital for
a while he decides to stay in grady
after falling in love with charming
ambulance driver lou played by julie
warner
in cars cocky young car lightning
mcqueen is riding across the country on
his way to a race until he crashes in
radiator springs and as a sentence for
the property damage he causes he's
forced to repair the road he decides to
stay in radiator springs after falling
for charming motel proprietor sally
the most idolized race car in cars is
easily the king
his name is after all the king and that
nickname comes straight from richard the
king petty the all-time winningest racer
in nascar history who voices his pixar
counterpart older viewers and racing
fans may notice a couple of famous
on-the-track events from petty's
illustrious career adapted into the
action of cars
in the film's climactic race the king
suffers a horrific spin-out and crash
mirroring one the real petty endured in
the 1988 daytona 500. in a show of
remarkable sportsmanship and growth for
the once incredibly selfish individual
lightning mcqueen cut short his assured
win to push the king across the finish
line a similar event went down at
daytona in 1976 although it was petty's
pit crew that helped him finish the race
not another racer check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite movies
are coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]